[Musique]
la main
les achats de vente d'objets les gâteaux
ici on a un spectacle théâtre flâneur
depuis trois ans des collégiens de
plusieurs établissements de l'ouest se
mobilisent afin de financer un projet
d'envergure faire un voyage humanitaire
au népal à la fin du mois d'avril
et ce jour là la classe musique à une
visite des oiseaux qui chantent et qui
fait de la musique pour aider ce projet
dont mary barry et marie alice sinaman
donne un concert à la salle luc donat au
tampon le 1er février et pour le voyage
au népal certains groupes fabrique des
fours solaires d'autres des lunettes
ce groupe sera chargé de raconter
l'histoire de la réunion à travers la
musique
[Musique]
il a besoin de la main mais pas d'une
société nous vive puisque hier sa maman
puisque yen où il faut nous donner parce
que sinon nous nous savons que nous
sommes à ce tête à tête en bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce projet leur fait du bien parce que
c'est une grande ouverture
donc on va rencontrer des enfants qui
sont finalement dans une situation bien
plus délicate
qui n'ont pas du tout les mêmes moyens
une autre culture complètement
différents mais qui a quand même des
points communs carignon notamment au
niveau de lyndiane i t3 deuxième cause
et a pris bien causer mais souvent ils
passent par là de mon nouveau n'est pas
là pour angers comme territoire
l'étranger envoûtés par la puissante
mélodie du fond de coeur
ces jeunes rêvent d'ailleurs une
confiance dans l'avenir transmises par
leurs aînés de quoi à leur permettre
d'aller pouvoir
[Musique]